في ايطاليا ايضا تشهد البلاد واكبر عمليات
تنصت في العالم تحت ذريعه مكافحه جرائم
العصابات المنظمه واحباطها حيث يوصف
التنصت على الهواتف بطريقه الوحيده
لاختراق عصابات المافيا ومعرفه الصفقات
الفاسده التي يبرمها كبار المسؤولين
والموظفين في الدوله غير ان افرادا وزعماء
من المافيات باتوا قادرين على معرفه اذا
كانوا تحت الرقابه او لا وذلك من خلال
تعاملهم مع اشخاص قادرين على الوصول الى
قوائم التنصت السريه لقاء مبالغ ماليه
وفقا لصحيفه تايمز البريطانيه وفي هذا
الاطار تجادل جهات حول جدوى عمليه التنصت
التي تكلف خزينه الدوله نحو 200 مليون
يورو سنويا فالاجهزه الايطاليه تراقب
هواتف نحو 110 الاف شخص من رجال العصابات
وتجار المخدرات والموظفين الذين يشتبه في
فسادهم الاداري لكن مراقبين يؤكدون ان هذه
التكاليف يمكن تعويضها من خلال كميات
الاموال الضخمه التي تجري مصادرتها من
عمليات المافيات او صفقات الفساد
[موسيقى]